yesterday it was the Trump's 13th
wedding anniversary and I looked it up
the traditional gift for the 13th
anniversary is lace yeah yeah for a
second Melania got excited and said I
thought you said mace so this morning I
guess y'all heard the news this morning
Meryl Streep was nominated for an
Academy Award
yeah or as that's called in Los Angeles
the first sign of spring that's pretty
much I think this is like her 22nd I
think yeah I think cake hold her up this
morning to tell which is like you woke
me up to that Christopher Plummer who
replaced Kevin Spacey in a film received
an Oscar nomination yeah afterwards
plumber called Spacey to thank him for
being a creep I worked out that's
actually a Hallmark card yeah thank you
thanks for being a creep
you